Roger stone joins us tonight he's been
in the news all day he's the author of a
new book called the myth of Russian
collusion Roger stone thank you for
joining us thank you good to be here
Tucker I'm a little tired but I'm glad
to be here so just just to get the
mechanics of what happened this morning
out of the way we've seen the tape shot
by CNN which remarkably was across the
street from your house very early this
morning and we saw the very large number
of armed federal agents bringing you out
of the house is there something we don't
know do you have an Arsenal at home had
you made threats against prosecutors
sorts of violence I mean is there
context that we don't have no first of
all it's disconcerting that CNN was
aware that I would be arrested before my
lawyers were informed that's disturbing
if it was a dangerous situation which
would merit the SWAT team well then
CNN's cameraman would be in danger I
don't know why they would be allowed to
be there
I had no firearm in the house I don't
have a permit for a firearm I don't own
a firearm only my wife my two dogs and
my three cats were at home I'm not a
flight risk in fact I think my passport
has expired or it will expire in a few
days I have no record of criminal past
and frankly they just could have
contacted my attorney and I would have
voluntarily turned myself in the proof
of this is that only hours later the
judge granted me a $250,000
surety bond meaning on my signature with
no funds put forward because I'm not a
flight risk and as far as the
government's contention that they were
concerned that I would destroy evidence
they've been in my email and my text
messages and my phone calls for two
years probably longer because the New
York Times reported on January 20 to
Gerry 20th 17 that I was among three
people in the Trump campaign under
active surveillance hopefully we'll
learn something about that in discovery
of this case oh so that's actually that
gets right to the heart of the
against you which are primarily for
lying to Congress and one of the things
you're accused of lying to Congress
about is whether or not there was any
evidence you had evidence of
communication between you and an
intermediary and Julian Assange did you
yes again given that you knew that they
had your electronic communications and
would know the answer already
wouldn't that be a stupid thing to lie
about what is this charge of yeah yeah
yes and dude it's really simple I did
forget that I had text messages from an
old cellphone that were entirely
exculpatory which proved that everything
I had said about critical being my
source regarding the significance and
the October release date of the
WikiLeaks material was accurate I
believe he lied to the grand jury about
that that's been reported but he appears
not to be being prosecuted for perjury
but I forgot exculpatory information and
therefore I will if anybody had bothered
to read my my website the stone-cold
truth they would know that I'm basically
refuted and documented the refutation of
virtually every charge in this
indictment the indictment is thin indeed
so what is this about
it's about silencing me there's a war on
alternative media there's a war where
they're trying to criminalize political
expression there's a war where they're
trying to criminalize free speech the
efforts to shut down my show at Infowars
the efforts to silence Alex Jones who's
one of my greatest supporters and
proponents are part of this war so I
intend to plead not guilty I believe I
will be vindicated it's funny to watch
Preet Bharara on CNN say this is a slam
dunk calls me a liar here's a guy who a
federal judge lashed for lying in the
William Walton case you're the liar
Preet so and then watching reporters
jump to conclusions Tucker and say oh
well the the were the Trump campaign
official who directed stone to find out
about WikiLeaks was Donald Trump no it
was not there are several things in here
in the indictment that are certainly not
so who was it if it wasn't the president
who was well I have to speculate about
that because since it never happened it
appears to me that they have composed
testimony for someone perhaps Rick Gates
perhaps Steve Bennett perhaps someone is
bearing false witness against me but
knowing what's in my email and my text
messages
there is no corroboration whatsoever for
this and as for my email exchange with
Steve Benton everything I told him in
the exchange was publicly reported
information Politico reported that after
Assange announced on October 1st that he
had nothing that day but would have
releases every week for the next ten
weeks and that all information on the
election pertaining the election would
be released in the weeks before the
election that was public information and
it also been reported that Assange had
security concerns that day so the two
things I told Ben and were public
information not the slightest bit
controversial Wes for the claim that
when and how did you learn that
WikiLeaks had these stolen emails when
Julian Assange said it on CNN on July
22nd 2016 and then repeated it on Fox on
August 24th this was not a state secret
Randi credit Co was the source who told
me that the the material was significant
dynamite a bombshell and so on and then
it would be released in October there's
also I think a reference to dr. Corsi in
here dr. jerome corsi
who told me in an e-mail when he was an
italy August 2nd that the WikiLeaks
disclosures would come shortly
thereafter and there'd be another one
immediately after that in August that
all turned out to be incorrect so
there's no evidence that I received
anything whatsoever from WikiLeaks that
I knew the subject or the content of
this material right well that's used to
silence not even that's not even in here
the the allegations as far as I'm
reading it is is that you you lied to
this congressional committee have you
spoken to the president about this I
have not but again if you watch CNN or
MSNBC you wouldn't know that because
they act as if stone act as the conduit
between the Trump Kane
Payne and WikiLeaks are between Donald
Trump and WikiLeaks when the president
answered the written interrogatories he
correctly and honestly said Roger stone
and I never discussed this and we never
did so it's clear I mean it's clear from
reading the indictment and you've been
saying it for at least a year that the
feds were spying on your texts there's
no question about it no question I agree
based on based on the indictment that
they released today so given they're
reading all of your texts you text with
a huge not happen to know a huge number
of journalists including me and some of
them you know work for CNN even maybe
all of those texts were being read by a
federal prosecutor what do you think
those journalists some of whom are
talking about this case right now on TV
think of that you know the that's the
amazing thing as the press is not coming
out and standing up against this war
against free expression this war against
the First Amendment which is really a
war against the press look Tucker I
think we both know the game here we're
stoned down financially make sure that
he's broke so that he has to plead
guilty to these charges that even though
he didn't commit them and then try to
flip me against the president I'm facing
two million dollars now in potential
legal fees people can go to stone
Defense Fund calm to help me stone
Defense Fund calm I'm in for the fight
of my life but I will not quit I will
not fold I will not Bend I will not bear
false witness against the president I
intend to fight because this indictment
is is is fabricated this indictment is
thin as as can be
my attorneys are highly confident that
they can win an acquittal if I can get a
fair trial in the District of Columbia
what what are the potential consequences
you face what are your lawyers telling
you they believe prosecutors will push
for in terms of a sentence it's
impossible to say they have not yet had
discussion the only other thing I do
want to say is the FBI agents this
morning were were extraordinarily
courteous after the initial
confrontation in which I was handcuffed
but I was then take
into the federal courthouse where I was
shackled hand and foot and went through
and had to sit in the holding cell
before the judge the judge was
imminently fair a issuing bond I'm
restricted in my travel I can only
travel to the District of Columbia New
York City and southern Florida but I'm
not a flight risk I'm 66 years old and
I'm essentially broke since the leaks
from the special counsels office over
the last two years have dried up my
consulting business since the censorship
and shadow banning on face book have
substantially dried up my book sales as
you know I had to end my life and health
insurance in December because I could
meet the premiums anymore every dollar I
scrape up has to go to this fight but
still I fight odd I mean do you notice a
theme here it seems like everyone who
gets ground up in the gears of this
investigation lacks the resources to
really fight back I mean I noticed that
no one called Podesta has been pulled
into this but it's you who can't afford
health insurance it's Papadopoulos who I
seems broke it's carter page who do you
expect the prosecutor will indict next
if anyone where's this going well I have
no idea they seem to be in hot pursuit
of dr. Jerry Corsi dr. Corsi said a
number of things about me that are not
true but he says he won't testify
against the president I have the emails
and text messages and metadata to prove
that many of the allegations he's made
against me are not true but he clearly
is referred to blindly of course in this
indictment I mean just take three steps
back who cares no offense to jerome
corsi who seems like a nice guy but does
anyone in America believe that Jerome
Corsi is in any way or any sense of
threat to American national security our
way of life or democracy I mean is he it
seems crazy I don't think I don't think
so nor do I think that legitimate
political or journalistic inquiry
regarding
what the topic of the WikiLeaks
disclosures is should be criminalized I
never received any any purloined
material and no I never knew that John
Podesta Z mails had been stolen in
advance and my tweet is not a reference
to that and a research memo that Jerry
Corsi wrote me regarding the Podesta is
extensive and lucrative business
dealings in Russia is not part of a
cover-up because no cover-up was
required so let me ask you there's a
last question when you when you watch
the clip that we played I don't know if
you had time to watch the coverage of
you on television today or you read the
internet and see people cheering for you
to get raped in prison or people
celebrating your indictment what do you
make of that where does that come from
well I must tell you we're a very bad
place in terms of our politics I get
four or five death threats a week I
can't go out to a public restaurant or
an airport or travel by myself now
because people want to mix it up they
don't want to just yell at you some of
them want to take a swing at you you
know I don't feel that way about them I
disagree with them but I'm not for
violence I don't think violence solves
anything green so it means again now I
need security for my family for myself
and that costs money which is why I've
asked the the public for help Roger
stone will be following it thanks for
coming on thank you very much thank you
Tucker